[Music]
as we have studied the student loan
crisis as an epic failure in america
um 1.7 trillion dollars in student loan
debt 45 million people carrying this
debt around their necks
when we do know
that mathematically you could choose a
community college you can choose an
in-state school you can work you can get
scholarships and you can go to school
debt-free but people are making choices
like that very nice gentleman's uh young
daughter
being influenced by her
mother his ex-wife
to make a stupid decision and pay money
to get virtually the same education but
is but but go into debt to do it and
it's just a disaster
but rachel said something as we started
talking about this about three years ago
this stuck with me that we really do not
have
a student loan crisis we really have a
parenting crisis
so in his case he has a parenting crisis
because he cannot completely make the
decision because he's got his ex
in the mix messing up the decision
but um and your parents who say well
they're 18 they can do whatever they
want if they're 18
you need to have
more influence in their life they live
under your roof eat your food drive your
freaking car and are on your cell phone
plan
so they're not free agents
they are a dependent
which means they are dependent on your
butt
and they need to understand that so you
want to be mean to your kids or rough
with your kids or something like that i
never was that but no one was in no one
was confused about who was running the
asylum it wasn't the inmates
you know and so
we have a parenting crisis a guy called
up and said well my son told me he was
going this expensive school see that's
we never had that conversation my kids
don't get to tell me stuff i told them
stuff
well you didn't listen to them well
that's why they're in counseling now but
they don't have any debt okay so it's
unbelievable
so the parenting crisis moms and dads is
you need to start
today
if your kid is 1
11 or 18
you need to start today
saying we're not going to have student
loan debt we're going to go in and get
post high school education at a trade
school at a tech school or a four-year
degree but we're not doing it with debt
so we need to be thinking about how
we're going to do that and you can start
talking about that at any age
this is we are a non-debt family
you will not be going into debt
we are going to figure out a way for you
to go to college without that we're
going to save up money and if you want
the money that's in my name that we
saved up for your use you will do it my
way baby because i have your best
interests at heart this is what's known
as a benevolent dictatorship
i'm benevolent but i own the freaking
money and i love you so much i'm not
going to participate in your craziness
start talking to your kids early about
this we've forgotten that college is for
education not for the landscaping and
the people that went in
i don't know what's going on who knew
college was not for your pleasure and
entertainment
oh i thought that's what it was for
give me a break that was sarcasm in case
you people didn't know me